so
now here's the other problem
i'm going to put you in venezuela
okay so you're in venezuela and you have
a choice you can buy one company in
venezuela or the entire index of
venezuelan stocks or you can buy one
building in venezuela or all the
buildings in venezuela or you can buy
one bond in venezuela or all the
venezuelan bonds
give me a diversification strategy which
is going to actually keep you from
losing all your money over five years if
you're sitting in venezuela five years
ago what is it
they're all correlated you see
it's like
you're on you're shuffling deck chairs
on you know on the titanic the ship is
sinking
you're shuffling these deck chairs the
fundamental elephant in the room here is
when the currency collapses right give
me a diversification strategy for
russian stocks right now which of those
do you want to own when the currency
collapses
the bonds collapse that are that are
linked to the currency
all the companies that generate cash
flows and the currency they all collapse
because they're valued as a stream of
cash flows and if the cash is worthless
how is the company going to be valuable
right you sell beef in argentina the
peso collapses the people are buying the
beef and pesos so you want to sell the
beef to europeans for euros the
government passes a law keeping you from
selling the beef or exporting your beef
export controls come wage and price
controls come
so the problem is every equity
every piece of debt every piece of
property linked to the currency is
correlated to the currency
so your diversification strategy with
any given currency whether it's the peso
the dollar the euro the ruble
the lira the whatever they're all
correlated so then you're like okay well
this is great i'm just going to buy the
dollar
all the currencies are correlated to the
dollar and the dollar is collapsing
how fast is the dollar collapsing
well you can you can watch it against
real estate in miami beach
right you know you can walk all you got
to do is look at the at the dollar
versus any scarce desirable piece of
property so what's the dollar valued in
versus a picasso a leonardo da vinci a
city block in new york city a desirable
piece of bench beachfront property and
how about palm beach right what's
happened to palm beach property in the
past 10 years
so ultimately the problem with
diversification is
nearly everything every stock is
correlated and and every every
conventional asset is generally
correlated the only true diversification
is if you find
non-sovereign stores of value
stores of value that have val that
derive their value based upon something
other than the cash flows that you could
derive from them
right so
you know think hard about what those are
real pristine trophy properties
might protect you
but i think um
i think that the problem ultimately is
is
if you're on a sinking ship
you have to get off the ship
and the problem with diversification
like when you're in the retail industry
and when it's completely getting
obliterated by amazon
you have to get off you have to get out
there's no winning strategy no matter
how you diversify in
and so
most of the time these models inflation
is two percent or cpi and you know we
should stay diversified they're based
upon this very conventional wisdom that
i live in this safe world and nothing
has changed
like there is no
when godzilla shows up to the playground
the rules of the game change
right
if there's an external factor
right you have this model it's like it's
always been like this it's always traded
like this in the last 30 years
well the us dollar never collapsed in
the past 30 years the us dollar is
losing 7 percent of its value for 30
years so your model says buy property
and buy the s p index
what happens when the us dollar is
losing 21 percent of its value
right it's like that's a different thing
and i
i think that
if we come back to energy
energy is life
and and if i suck the energy out of this
room i freeze you to death right when i
when i suck the energy out the
temperature keeps falling if the
temperature is falling one two percent
you can crank it up and try to deal with
it but when the temperature is falling
ten percent
at some point you'll start to freeze if
i if i pull enough energy out of the
room fast enough and at that point you
have to entertain a new notion an oxygen
mask
you know put on a coat you got to exit
the room eventually
and
if we come back to this issue right the
issue of the day is ukraine but what's
really going on here
the currency and the banking systems
have collapsed in afghanistan
in iraq
they're falling and collapsing in turkey
they've collapsed in lebanon
and syria they're not trustworthy
in ukraine and in russia
now i've just lassoed about 400 million
people
and those 400 million people don't have
a currency that they can use as a medium
of exchange or a store of value
they don't have banks that they trust
that work effectively
and
what's the fundamental issue here it's
like if you don't have a property or a
currency with which you can store
economic energy that's like being a type
one diabetic you cannot store fat on
your body it means that you can eat as
much as you want you will literally
starve to death
right because you don't have the ability
to store energy fat is organic energy
just like property is uh is a
manifestation of energy
in low frequency
i give you a billion dollars and the
currency it's high frequency money i get
i buy a billion dollar building i hold
it for 30 years it's low frequency
money
right either way
okay i give you a billion dollars you
buy a building in in some central
african republic someone puts a gun to
your head takes your building now you
have no building
you buy a billion dollars worth the
currency the currency collapses because
the guy that runs the country prints
more of it it goes to zero
you know like uh
paper money in venezuela is not as
valuable as toilet paper right now
what is it right not not clear so
what you have is an economic collapse
and
it's a global phenomenon today and it
was accelerated in march of 2020
right the catalytic event the catalyst
for these things normally is a war
a war on covid
a war on currency
a war on a lot of things we're fighting
a lot of wars right now and now we've
got real wars right a political and
actual war in ukraine
wars collapse currencies they always
have world war one collapsed the
currency world war ii also damaged the
currency you can actually trace it if
you look at real estate values in the
years that follow the war
right so what we're doing is we're
collapsing the currency and you could
describe the entire world right now as 8
billion people
there's one strongest currency the
dollar which is losing 15 to 20 percent
of its value a year
that's how fast it's bleeding out you've
got to say you've got a set of tier of
currencies pegged to the dollar sing you
know singapore the middle east the euro
that are fairly uh fairly close to the
dollar then you've got a set of
second-tier currencies the peso and and
the the turkish lira and the like and
they're losing 40 percent the rubble now
losing 40 50 percent of their value a
year and you get the third tier
currencies
the venezuelan you know the boulevard et
cetera they pretty much hyperinflate
they all collapse and they're all going
to dollarize
this this trend is going to continue
crypto falls into this trend because
what's happening is people realize
they can't trust their local currency
they can't trust their local bank
if you don't trust the bank why don't
you trust the bank and canada right the
bank might seize my assets if they
disagree with me
in afghanistan the banks all failed you
know when the u.s pulled out and lebanon
the banks basically closed froze
everybody's assets
seized and converted all their foreign
currency assets into local lebanese
money devalued the money and they locked
it up for 10 years
okay so when you have hundreds of
millions if not billions of people
losing faith in the currency losing
faith in the banks what do you do
you look for the digital solution and
the digital solution is i download a
mobile app to my phone
and then i convert whatever asset or
work or property i have into a
cryptocurrency
and there's two things that i really
want badly
one thing i want badly is crypto dollars
like tether or circle or the like it's
basically u.s dollars sitting on crypto
rates stable coin stable coin
and the world's bought 190 100 and 890
billion of that from like 5 billion over
the past 24 months it's exploding
it will go to 10 trillion
if they could right the market has a
trillion to 10 trillion dollar demand
for that stable coin
what will happen when that happens
every one of these local weak currencies
collapses
right there's not a single currency in
africa in south america in asia you
would rather hold than the dollar right
now the chinese don't want to hold the
cny they would all convert to the u.s
dollar how do you know that because
there are capital controls every country
that implements a capital control making
it illegal to convert their currency or
move their capital out of the country is
signaling to you
that their currency is weak and that
includes the chinese currency
so that's one dynamic you've got 130
currencies floating in the world there's
probably only two or three that will be
left when the dust settles you got the
euro the cny the usd
everything else either gets pegged to
those or it collapses into those
and then the second thing the world
wants is once crypto property it wants
money to give to your grandchildren i i
want to hold my money for 100 years if
not a thousand years
the dollar won't work the dollar is
losing two percent of its value a month
which is horrific
and you know horrific over 36 months
it's catastrophic over 10 years
and people are getting smart enough to
realize that that won't work
so the issue is
where do i put my long-term money i need
a savings account
so hence this is where bitcoin comes in
bitcoin is the dominant crypto property
network in the world it's it's pretty
much the only
the only perfected
digital property network the human race
has created it's it's a proven digital
property
everything else is a speculation that it
may become property over time bitcoin is
the success and every like kind
competitive bitcoin has collapsed
against it such that bitcoin is the 95
dominant network in this space
the dollar is clearly the dominant the
dominant currency and it wants to be the
dominant digital currency it is really
the dominant digital currency as well
despite
despite the fact that the us government
doesn't have you know u.s banks issuing
them yet and we've been slow on the
uptake
you can see where this is headed
and the driver is the stampede of
everybody else in the world right you
know you're a rich american and you feel
comfortable with your banking structure
okay maybe you can ignore this but name
somebody in africa asia or south america
that can ignore this issue right now
right i mean i invite you to sell all
your money and move to a country in
africa and then invest it in local local
property local companies
local currencies and put in a local bank
and feel good about yourself so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye
[Music]